whoa dude so wait well I mean what made
her to say yes to you compare to the
other two guys then dude come on
whatever dude you [ __ ] dragons
[ __ ] [ __ ] the buckteeth with the
headgear [ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about yo when she got
with me I still had hella acne and buy
my teeth were still [ __ ] up
oh really yeah yeah you would be really
bad acne sick I was like 15 16 like
right around the time my my braces
disappeared acne came I was like are you
kidding me what the [ __ ] and it was bad
it was like all down here and then up
here and this is it was always here for
me the tea oh dude it's so bad I know I
tried so many things you know the what
is it the thing that was always on TV
elective
yes Proactiv yeah I've tried it so many
different times never worked it just
made my dress like skin so dry yeah it
was horrible I tried avvocato on my face
oh my god I try the best one that
actually worked
cinnamon and cinnamon and honey really
you put cinnamon like in a little Bowl
and you put honey on it and you mix it
and it looks like [ __ ] you know you put
it on your face and it looks like
somebody took a dump on you like a wet
dump but it works it alleviates it it's
it's not as redness yeah it's not as hot
and you know you want to scratch it yeah
that goes away and it
I mean I don't have scarring yeah so
well how'd you find out about the
cinnamon honey [ __ ] dude my mom I'll
really I would hate that [ __ ] that's my
fat ass my my mom gave me so many
different remedies and she engine is
hell and I was like it's not gonna work
like we live in America I'm trying
Proactiv so I tried Proactiv first for
however long I feel like it's too hard
to miss cinnamon yeah and then the
cinnamon honey work I was like you're
don't don't give me that look mom I
would've ate that [ __ ] so fast you have
no idea my god I just sat there it's
like weird dude what's your [ __ ] [ __ ]
goes like I hate it it was a snack I
couldn't help it I'll be honest the ones
that were on my upper lip at by the end
of the 30 minutes it was already guy I
don't know you had acne to do your
[ __ ] life growing up with [ __ ]
it wasn't the best it was the best so
when did you like start did you always
like dress fashionably
or damn I gotta see pictures of yourself
here this is one of those stories that
you hear where it was loaded the dude
that was bullied made fun of was a dweeb
and that suddenly became a [ __ ] model
with his younger brother on express did
that makes no [ __ ] sense man
cuz I'm still waiting for my moment but
it hasn't happened yet I'm like okay you
know what imma be that story you have a
clothing line what do you mean yeah but
I am hiring people like you to wear it
haha if I wear my own clothes I look
like [ __ ] so I'm trying to get other
people who wear that's so [ __ ] crazy
dude like I would have never thought
yeah well Peter the reason why we got
into fashion is cuz Peter actually both
of us had no sense of fashion Peter
never wore pants only cargo shorts only
cargo shorts all throughout high school
you can ask anyone with high school with
he only wear cargo shorts and a beanie
so like a really shitty beanie so he
could just like what put his [ __ ]
yo-yo cards in there [ __ ] possibly
possibly yes we loved you Gil okay you
guys you know what I'm not but you like
that toy put a target on our backs but a
lot of people like yugioh though I
remember even like some of my friends
like they [ __ ] with you go they didn't
like say it out loud no yeah but nobody
said it out loud but they did play you
yo cuz I played you yo when I was like
13 I think around there yeah I did for a
year because I like the first one out of
the group that played you yo but then I
got out of it after a year cuz I would I
became a 14 year old I'm not doing this
[ __ ] anymore but all my friends did so I
just gave my card to them on you guys
play it man you gave him your card I
have I still had well this I forgot how
[ __ ] has my [ __ ] oh I let this guy
borrow cuz he battled his decks and [ __ ]
so I was like I didn't sell it but I
still had like some dope [ __ ] I can't
remember what they already born because
I only did for a year but I gave it to
him
I like here you could borrow it and just
give it back he never gave it back to me
and then I was like where's my [ __ ] he
goes oh I don't have it I was like well
I have all your Trigun
he let me borrow all of his try couldn't
like cassette tapes and I was like well
until you give me those cards back your
whole [ __ ] tried and collected mine
yeah so here's a but I need that stuff
back I was like blowing you my cards
back so I still have the tracking stuff
in my closet at home in Sacramento in
case he brings it back yeah but he's
still not gonna get it because Italy
you've basically stole my [ __ ] dude of
limitations yeah like you stole my [ __ ]
well either you get your [ __ ] ass
beat I'm gonna beat your [ __ ] ass or
I'm gonna keep this [ __ ] so I still have
it so I still have this whole like
Trigon like tape collection yeah that's
so crazy is what it is dude so he was
battling him and he lost them it's
business told me didn't want you met
that's what it is I lost my stuff oh you
lost all of them oh yeah so Peter and I
quit so him into it did you watch the
show uh yeah the first couple you know
how they had that island yeah so we made
an island of our own we were we went to
a school that had like a park next to it
and then there was an island on it so
one day after school like on a Friday I
was like you know we're gonna make a
tournament you guys pay us $10 we made
wristbands out of double-sided tape and
then you we made stars so you know how
you start with two stars you know most
people sell drugs and they they do cool
[ __ ] like that
this [ __ ] decided to do a you yo
tournament I let me tell you something I
got bullied but then as somebody who got
bullied I would have bullied you why are
you doing this is I need to do it to you
so they don't get to you first right I I
mean I know I've put a target on my back
but it was just what I enjoyed now
there's what you know what that's the
best way to do it there's nothing to do
I was like I so we made this tournament
and we had the two stars for everybody
they paid me $10 and Peter joined the
game so I was the game holder and I was
like cool all this pot I'm taking 50%
winner gets 50 mm-hmm right we had like
four hundred dollars five hundred others
coming so I got him a lot of kids played
that [ __ ] dude we had to it I mean again
Asian school oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right so we still had it was like
still kind of cool but you know like not
to the point where you make a freaking
tournament right yeah but it's okay a
lot of people ended up coming and and I
was also selling Costco candy at the
same time okay so when they come in I
was like if you want candy while you're
walking around so it was like cuz that
lasted about 3-4 hours so they it was
like they had to get the stars from each
other and whatever they were battling
each other and Peter ended up winning oh
well he beat this other guy but the guy
got like really upset that he didn't win
he was like you guys are cheating this
cuz you're brothers I was like listen
here we'll split the winning pot between
you and Peter's oh yeah he got 125 Peter
gotta hunt 25 so we made out with like
300 something yeah like in like
junior high that's [ __ ] crazy dude
how often people got pissed off no we
did the one time stuff and they found
our cards insult stole stole them all so
we no longer had any cards they stole
your car yes because we could we
couldn't play my parents were like this
is the devil's work so you can't play
this so what we did was we saved up
money to get the first deck like the
start of it and when we got back Peter
was so good at strategize strategizing
and all that stuff and I was good at
like meeting the right people so I would
be like yo who wants to play my brother
for keeps so we would play decks for
keeps because some people had a lot of
different decks they're like sure I'll
play you there's no way your starter
deck because we're like we're only using
the starter deck that we got you know
everybody knows what's in it so they
know how to counter it yeah so though I
can just know you're gonna beat us a
Peter found a way to counter him yeah
with the deck that he was given and he
bought it like a booster and put some
stuff in there and he beat him and he
got more and more more cards who stole
your [ __ ] we don't know to this day we
have no idea did you go we got home and
we lost the whole tune we had a big old
10 like that and there was nothing in
there you guys are so nice dude like if
somebody stole my [ __ ] [ __ ] I would
find that [ __ ] dude I don't even
[ __ ] what were we gonna do we would have
gotten our asses kicked
oh that's these are different times this
ha ha ha Peter Peter could fight mmm he
was smaller and skinnier but he was
always scrappier and he could fight I I
would I would have gotten my ass beat I
would have been like what's the point
I'm gonna I'm gonna go find this guy and
then he's gonna beat me up yeah it's
like even for me like well I guess I
wouldn't have gotten my cards really
stolen because I don't know if people
would just don't give a [ __ ] about cards
back in the day they would just stole
cars just to be an [ __ ] about right
and they would have trashed it in front
of your face but oh well yeah because
like there's no value to that right
because like in my high school there was
value to shoes there was cards also the
[ __ ] you know shoes drugs and [ __ ] like
that so it wasn't like cards weren't
really [ __ ] hairs you know like you know
this said there's like my mice group of
friends that I really liked so like I
was like [ __ ] cat allergies my right
eyes about to get rid but oh I was like
I feel it too yeah so I start rubbing
when I forgot about it but you were
touching the kept I forgot but either
way I so I used to like flowing around
different groups right so yeah it was
like the group that I stated in high
school they were really cool people
they're very nicely played you guild
cards and you know they watch the anime
and
[ __ ] which is really Who I am now that's
the guy who I am you know but you know
when you grow up in a bad neighborhood
you kind of feel like you should fit
into this group of people that you grew
up with so these people are the ones
that I liked a lot you know but they
that was a very I didn't realize how
small that subgroup was I kids it was
like the honors Honor Roll class the
only reason why I got to know these guys
is because my parents forced me to join
her on a roll
but I suck I got C's I got DS you know I
mean I wasn't good at this [ __ ] I do
that stuff but I got but fortunately for
my parents they forced me to do it then
I actually met these good people they're
still my friends till this day so like
for them it was so weird because I I
related them the most when I started
joining honorable classes that's like oh
these people are my my flow like hey
yeah they're really nice you know they
[ __ ] play your cards they watch anime
[ __ ] I like I like these guys many
better than some of my other friends
from from where I grew up you know so
like after a while I just started
kicking it with them and I was like oh
this is this is definitely a lot more my
speed
and so when I remember when they were
playing yugioh cards house like I don't
hide a shame but I would like float
around a lot of different groups and it
was so weird because like I you know you
just don't know who you are as yeah it's
kind of cool for you because you just
said [ __ ] him jump me did you guys have
like a lot of gangs in your school was
just a very nice school um you know to
me I had no idea that there were all
that stuff I was so sheltered yeah that
I had no idea but there we had a lot of
like gay pride gangs oh you like Korean
guys yeah yeah so we had a lot of that
and apparently like somebody died in our
high school I had no idea no cuz I was
so sheltered I didn't think anything
happened I thought everybody was a
virgin bro yeah I honestly I was so
sheltered like because he punished
ideals yeah all I did was just play my
games do my things I had create I
co-created the anime club in my high
school yeah literally everybody was like
you stupid [ __ ] you're gonna get your
ass beat yeah and it was like and I was
okay so there was one point in school
where I passed by this room and I saw
people rummaging in there like there was
like three or four people and they were
like rummaging through this stuff
and I saw was like the heck yeah all the
backpacks were there was only three
people and some guy comes up to me
younger guy like younger grade and it
comes up so I came in we're cool right
I was like yeah bro yeah so he's like
not gonna tell anybody that were in here
taking in this stuff right I was like I
was like I was looking like well I
didn't know until you told yeah like I
was like no no no of course man and then
and then they got one of the girls who
was like one of the hot girls in school
to come up it was like okay yeah I like
touch my hand I was like okay cool cool
and I like walk past ran straight to the
teachers and a tattled on the haha and
then they they caught him but a lot of
the stuff was already gone but they
caught him and all there was like four
people three or four people and they all
got like expelled
obviously oh good yeah and everybody in
that classroom was really like thank you
thank you thank you
and the teacher would thank you shut the
[ __ ] up do dare [ __ ] pin this on me
and that was a biggie man it was like
when they saw that the guys that were
like being escorted out of the school
they were like we're coming for you yeah
oh [ __ ]
and nothing ever happened thank God but
every time I saw them anywhere near the
like the town I was like I would - man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude
I was in cross country so I was fast I
was good at I was like you wait you may
be faster on you're very honorable man
dude like I wouldn't even have computers
I would just been like they're like
you're not gonna tell anybody I was like
guess don't know what's going on
how does is what about my way cuz you
know you know just like growing up like
yeah if you mind your own business like
nothing would happen you guys don't like
that's a good good on you though it's
cuz i watch all those animes right
you're like you gotta be the hero yeah
yeah like shut up kid I'll just be like
shiny [ __ ] dude
milli you see [ __ ] right I guess not and
then I would have realized after what
they were doing like a month later I'll
say stupid they said that they were
stealing stuff but they're dumb I would
have been like I woulda just watch
that's like rule number one like you
don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] yeah just you
steal stuff like you know you're
supposed to do it yeah like that's just
keep going to buy your business you
don't have to tell me nothing when I was
in I don't
you're high there's a guy whose name is
Chaka Chaka Hassan I remember this guy
I feel like flunk like seven times I
think he was like 38 by the time he was
in junior high this guy so [ __ ] old
but like I just grew up kind of getting
bullied a lot but the difference is is
that I was just a kid that just didn't
allow people to ball me believe me
because I was a big kid - were you
always talk I was this size when I was
14 I was big already I was like 6-1 6-2
ish around there and so but you know I
was a very nice dweeby kid right but
because I